your life chairman thank you
good evening members and colleagues
welcome to this planning meeting of
malden district council today thursday
the 7th of april
2022
this meeting is being streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving consent to being
recorded
welcome also to our youtube viewers at
home as we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording
my name is councillor mark hurd and i'm
chairman of morton district council
members if you wish to speak on any item
please indicate and i will invite you to
speak at the appropriate time you may
remain seated please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions clear and concise
please note the sound recording of this
meeting is dependent on the correct use
of microphones therefore when invited to
speak turn on your microphone and turn
it off when finished
please avoid the top table area as the
cameras here are live and the feeds are
hazardous and affect our streaming
i would also like to advise that the
fire exit is the door behind this top
table there are no alarms expected
we'll move on to agenda item two
apologies for absence uh good evening
miss bird
good evening good evening members thank
you apologies for the community from
council of bussinger councilman
councillor bell councillor edwards
council mays councillor known council
thank you i know that uh several members
are unwell and we wish them we wish them
well
agenda item three
are minutes of the previous meeting it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting of the district planning
committee held on the 3rd of march 22
found on pages 7 to 12 are approved as a
true and accurate record and these are
presented for accuracy only i so move do
i have a secondary
councillor fluker thank you very much
can we agree those by sent members
thank you very much
agenda item 4 declarations of interest
members are reminded that they are
required to declare any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interests which they know they might
have in items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive for the code of conduct for
members
they are reminded that they will need to
repeat their declarations at the
appropriate point
and leave the room if required under the
code of conduct
unforeseen interests must be declared
similarly at the appropriate time
to have any
declarations councillor durham
thank you chairman i have a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council who are statutory
council teas and have been consultees on
quite a number of items pertaining to
this application thank you
thank you very much council fleming
thank you chairman and non-pecunory as a
member of essex county council who are
statutory consultees thank you
thank you very much any other members
thank you very much those are noted
uh we now move to uh agenda item five
the reference is two one
zero zero seven five two res
this is land at broad street green
road maple road and langford road
haybridge this reserved matters
application is submitted to this
committee as it is a
strategic site within the strategic
submitted local development plan
it is for the approval of access
appearance landscaping layout and scale
for the construction of 160 residential
units
with associated access parking servicing
and landscaping
the officer presenting this report
uh will be doing so remotely um
which is um anna tashtoglu good evening
anna can you hear me
yes i can hear you thank you thank you
very much could you present your report
please
yes let me just show you my screen
um
are you all able to see my screen
yes we can see it thank you
great
so the application relates to the
largest of the three sites allocated for
development in the north hebrews garden
suburb referred to in policy as the s2d
north of hayward site which was
currently planned and said for a hybrid
mixed-use development on appeal on the
25th of october 2019
under the terrorist
the current proposal relates to phase
one of the approved development and in
particular london is reserved for the
delivery of residential parcels one and
two
as you can see on the plan
both parcels are located to the east of
maple road
which is here and they form the
westernmost part of the approved
development of habits current suburb
it should be noted that the development
does not include the land that is
necessary to approve the strategic
landscaping and infrastructure elements
and such as roads and sas
and these elements of phase one were
previously
approved at the district planning
committee on
september
wrote improvements on main road and all
the landscaping surrounding the two
parcels
was also approved
phase plan was recently approved and the
map here shows the agreed phase one in
blue
so whatever you see in blue is
phase one of the development
[Music]
associated access parking servicing and
landscaping
as shown on the layout plan here
these are two plants showing at
the compliance of the development with
the parameter plants
here is the test it's from the plant
there are two different
densities
within these
residential persons and the close
development complies
with this plan
also the building heights
three different types of kites allowed
within this um
section of the the
section of the
application
with three stories maximum three stars
only allowed along
the spine road and a small area here
um
adjacent to
maple road
we have only two uh facility buildings
here one of my countries majority of the
site is two story with three uh
at the center of person one
the development also includes 30
affordable here on this plan you can see
the position of the affordable units
rented and set honestly
building heights as i have already
explained
materials layout and development
includes a number of phasing series
including free and worth boarding and
red and slave and terracotta roof
roof tires
this is the immediate layout the
development following amendments
complies with the
standards within the
modern district design spd in terms of
main space
this is the landscape strategy layout
which solves the type of trees and
shrubs and hatreds for the african poses
within the site
and the management responsibilities
layout
the public open space
will be managed by a company they
communal space is to be upgraded
some technical drawings
highlight several arrangements on the
solid parcel
of the northern parts of the process and
the southern part
and the refugees layout
these are some streets in elevations and
off the sides
for example the top one shows the
views of the
northern parcel the
uh
these are the
easternmost
street scene
here the second one is the northern part
of uh along the spine roads of the
southern parcel
moving on
here we have some streets and elevations
from within the parcels mainly
more so it's in elevations like oops
the top one is the
western part of the northern parcel
the middle one is the western um
innovation of the southern person
and the development includes quite a
number of different types of dwellings
and i have included some
some of them for you to get an
understanding of how the development
would look like
so here we have some
two-bedroom market units
these are two bedroom affordable units
uh three bedroom market units
this is a three bed affordable
and
again three bedroom market units
and this is a two-story building with
two two bedroom flats and they're both
affordable
here is a four bedroom market you need
and another one
and this is the five bedroom market you
need proposed within the site
uh here is the node the block of flood
which is allocated on the northern
parcel
north east part of the parts of the
northern parcel and the plants
and here are the
the only three story
units proposed within the
home site
and two and a half so these are flats
and masonites
and these are the market units uh
similar overall
appeals and design powerful
materials
here are the galaxies
and
carbons
[Music]
i have also included some of the visuals
that the applicant has submitted these
are not to be uh part of the approved
plans but they just give a feeling of
how the development would look like
another one
and another one
and here are some photographs of the
site
top one is beautiful main road towards
the part of the site
south is from within the side towards
maple road
and this is the view from within the
side towards the north and the existing
truck access
on the top you see the view towards the
south and the
uh some long views of the s2e site which
is also part of the northeast garden
suburb
south east
that forms the eastern parts eastern
boundary of the site and
also some views from a
holloway road which is further to the
south of the silence
so the principle of development these
scientists are already to be accepted
and as it forms part of the northeast
suburb
the details of the residential element
of phase one of the development are
considered to accord with the north
paris garden
uh strategic master plan framework the
north hayward's strategic design calls
the approved branch plans and the
outline plan
would be acceptable and it would be a
good representation of the villains
character that is aimed for this section
of the north
housing that is policy compliant and
would enhance the provision of mixed
communities
the housing mix proposed would be
balanced acceptable without prejudicing
prejudicing the deliverability of the
future phases of the approach
development
the proposal would provide a good level
of
quality of life for existing and the
future of buyers and apparently
provision that accords with the legal
parking standards spd
uh no protection is raised in terms of
the impact of development of the highway
safety or the highway network the impact
on existing visitation is acceptable
and the proposal will also deliver
biodiversity
on the basis of all the involved and
this this reserve matters application is
considered acceptable and officers
recommend approval of the application
subject to conditions
53-59
thank you anna we have one public
participant for this planning
application in line with the public
participation scheme i will now invite
the agent mr matthew wood
from phase two planning to read out his
submission now i remind you mr wood that
you are allocated two minutes only for
public speaking in accordance
with the scheme tara do we have the oh
we do have the time recording ready okay
thank you mr wood two minutes from when
you start speaking
good evening to members
as you will recall the wider application
site relates to the largest of the three
sites allocated for development
in the north haybridge garden suburb
with this reserved mata's application
seeking detailed consent for the first
phase of the residential element
during the course of this rm application
which itself has followed detailed
pre-application discussions the
applicant has worked positively with
officers and members to evolve the
scheme to its current position
as such
officers have now concluded that the
proposals as presented would be fully
acceptable as a good representation of
the village edge character that is aimed
for in this part of the suburb
the proposed housing mix closely aligns
with the associated requirements of the
outline planning permission both in
respect of private and affordable
housing
it is important to add that free private
bungalows
will be provided as part of this early
phase of the development with a
significant proportion of the bungalows
on future phases being of an affordable
tenure including a greater proportion in
closer proximity to the neighborhood
center
the proposed scheme has evolved to
ensure that a good standard of amenity
is achieved for all future occupiers of
the development including
full policy compliance in respect of
private amenity provision
officers committee report confirms the
acceptability of these detailed
proposals in all planning related
respects as part of its strong
recommendation for approval
therefore these detailed proposals
represent a sustainable and policy
compliant form of development and
members are urged to support this
recommendation and grant detailed plan
permission accordingly
finally it it is worth adding that in
march 2022 the countryside retained
their five-star house builder award and
a gold award from in-house for customer
satisfaction
and is delighted to be returning to the
malden district for their their first
phase of development in over 20 years
thank you very much for your time
thank you perfect time mr wood thank you
i'll now open the debate and invite you
to put any questions or make any
comments that you have on the report
councillor white
uh thank you mr chairman um now i i am i
know we are where we are um under 3.1.6
um i took it the subs were approved at
the last application which covers this
area as well i mean it says it in the
report but i just want to double check
um and i do take a little bit of a an
umbrage with the um
the member of the public saying that uh
they worked with members well if they've
worked with members they could have put
in the bridal ways but anyway moving on
um
so that was just my opinion i know he
doesn't like the bridal ways but i'm
sorry it's in our policies and the
applicants could have been
more helpful um now the other problem
i've got is um can officers confirm to
me that the residential care
neighborhood uses including shops and
sports will be ring fenced and will
happen
because with rising fuel and living
costs these are more important than ever
and we have a duty to improve the life
of people who live there now it's all
very well people say oh yes we'll do
this but in how many applications in
haybridge have these things not happened
and
i didn't want the application to be
approved it's approved appeal so we are
where we are but can officers assure me
this is going to happen because every
time we get a few houses built this
phase that phase the other phase but i
want to be sure that the
the nicer things do actually happen so i
don't there's any way we can condition
it or anything else but thank you
thank you um anna can you answer those
questions please
yes
i
okay thank you very much
cancer darum
oh thank you chairman
um
german
firstly i'll just make an observation
that we got less than 50
of our members here tonight
which i think is rather sound indictment
i know some members may feel that this
doesn't concern them
but of course this concerns the entire
district because the fact we don't have
a five-year land supply this
application is absolutely critical to us
having any chance of regaining that
until we get a five-year land supply
every single parish and district in the
every area in the district is
liable to be um
developed where we don't want it so you
know this is not just a haybridge matter
it's notable that there aren't actually
any local members
here i'm sure some have got good reasons
maybe the coveted card or maybe
well whatever we'll we'll leave it at
that shall we um
as i've said chairman you know we are
where we are this was given
uh approval on
on appeal we've granted the other
reserve matters this one does at least
accord to
the garden suburb design principles that
we were shown
many many years ago which cannot be said
for other developments um
elsewhere in uh elsewhere in the malden
area we won't go into that
so chairman i i think that you know
really
i did mention at the last meeting when
we had another reserve matters um
application that you know the sooner
these are brought forward and granted we
can start uh getting these properties
built
we can then start getting our five-year
land supply and we can start to get the
community benefits that come with it as
has just been highlighted and i think
that um
the other point i would make about the
um
the lack of attendance tonight uh should
it come to it i'm sure that is a point
that would be noted by a planning
inspector but we'll leave it at that
thank you okay
thank you cancer darren councillor
thompson
thank you chairman um
i don't know if miss castell could put
the pictures up of the
two and a half and three-story flats and
maisonettes
because i'm i'm i'm
really fairly happy with the designs
overall but
these particular units
just look disproportionate to me they
are
they're fairly ugly
i have to be honest
uh they're the ones thank you
um now i'm pretty sure in my own mind
although i know i'd be happy to have
that confirmed through mr lee that this
wouldn't justify the refusal
i'm sure it wouldn't but if there was
any way the applicants could tweak that
and come back without
causing delay or
aggro or anything else
i'd certainly be pleased to see it
anyway thank you
thank you celine
through chairman um
i don't think anyone's going to argue
that these are particularly high
and excellent design um
properties um but as kansadam said we
are in a situation with um
by the land supply we are in a situation
where we have design codes that have
accepted these height of properties um
it's a very difficult
question to answer because obviously
officers have recommended approval the
lpa thinks it is acceptable um
as always all i can say is that is the
tilted balance now
the weight is in favor of the developer
and
obviously as always it comes down to
decision maker but if you do think that
these the harm caused for the scale of
the overall development by these
properties is significant and that
benefits outweighs the harm then that
would form a release refusal but that is
within members gift obviously it's not
up to officers but because we've come to
our professional recommendation is that
the scheme is acceptable thank you did
you want to come back on that yes yes
i'm certainly not arguing about the
actual heights um you know as we said
they were agreed long ago it's just a
particular look of these particular
buildings and and now i'm not by any
stretch of the imagination suggest we
refuse a whole scheme just because i
don't like these buildings
i'm just saying okay
okay well
obviously we're inviting comments and uh
hopefully the developers might bear that
in mind
uh councillor boyce
chairman thank you i'm rather intrigued
by condition nine
um
uh and it could it
talks of the vehicle parking standards
of 2018 and it's about charging points
for electric cars
um
am i to understand
that
these are going to be attached to
the actual houses or some houses or are
they going to be a free-for-all
location for these charging points
i'm sure if it helps mr lee for the
benefit of the tape
i'm sure he's going to direct members to
page 48 of the parking standards spd
because that actually covers this off
and and can i say i'm delighted that
unlike other developers countryside
seemed to have picked up on page 48 and
actually executed it throughout this
document so well done to them
uh but i have got questions as well but
i'll
okay um actually i was going to go to uh
mr luke are you able to help with that
uh tool
yeah
um according to the uh
concerns svd one
electric starting point should be
provided
within each swelling at least one and
when you
okay thank you very much councillor
fluke are you okay with that yes thank
you very much chairman um uh but i'm i'm
just wondering if there's gonna be a
queue or how much punch-ups there might
be
to wanna uh connect
okay counselor fluker yeah thank you
john i um look my understanding of the
the parking standard occupancy is that
all all individual houses have one yeah
and then there's a percentage of others
and then there's an announce for parking
spaces i mean what concerns me
enormously is is that we've had this
discussion before with applications and
this hasn't been mentioned it's only
because i wanted to do that bit of
research this afternoon i actually found
this but as i said countryside picked up
on it um
could could i just draw your attention
to page 59 first
um and in particular formative number
seven once i get there so did i say 49 i
meant 59.
59 yeah you did say 59. yeah so 59
chairman i think there's a typo there uh
i'm not sure it's that relevant but i
think when i actually get to page 59
apologies like
ipad's not scrolling properly
i'm sure by now you would have found it
anyway
so the information i think chairman the
last word should say stage and not state
i mean i think we anybody involved in
the construction industry will know that
the building regulations are in the
state um but i actually think um that
should say stage and i think that's been
in mind this farm rescue i think that's
important to get that right chairman and
then if we could go back to page 32
which
which was my main point
and this is something which i'm gonna
we're going to need i believe some
advice from miss tesla glue um
and this gems to do with the
provision of bungalows under the
affordable housing
um
pat the last sentence of 5.216
just for the benefit of members it says
the applicant has confirmed that this
will be fully achievable and deliverable
throughout the remaining phases of
development so this means the actual
bungalows now chairman i'm not sure how
we're going to police that because we've
seen the way these developments
sometimes get carved up i suspect
economically
the developer would be keener german i
think to have affordable houses than
bungalows so
my question to the officer is chairman
is is how can we
condition that to make sure this
actually happens because we do have a
shortage of bungalows
and
you know there's a certain degree of
swerving in this and i i don't think
it's sufficient to
to not approve this application but i
think we do need to make sure that these
bungalows are
are delivered on this site chairman and
that we don't lose the opportunity and i
think so long as miss tatsu group can
come up with a condition
um to make sure that that happens
chairman i would propose that subject to
that condition we actually approve this
recommendation thank you
okay uh did you want to come back on
that please anna
yes yes please
[Music]
an affordable housing delivery plan was
approved submitted and approved
this allows this experience to provide
there is a certain number of forty three
five
correct um
one or two button buttons so they need
to be provided throughout the scheme
and
there is no requirement to be provided
in its phase necessarily but they need
to be provided um
within the scene
uh
we
wouldn't i don't think that we would
need to we would need to condition that
necessarily because this is this has
been considered as i said through the
affordable housing of the affordable
delivery
plan
and also
the
when we need to start raising concerns
because this is
phase one this is
around the 10
of the whole development that's going to
be delivered
within the site so and the
total amount of affordably used the
affordable bangalores and that they
should have been provided in these
phases six so we feel we're quite
comfortable that they can be provided in
future phases
the applicant has also submitted an
indicative plan
that shows
how these battles will be provided and i
can share my screen
and show you this plan of service with
members again this is not a plan that we
would be able to condition but it shows
how the developer considers uh providing
these bundles do you understand my
screen yeah yes yes please if you would
i think counselor fluker's question was
how can we police it
how do how will we know
i mean the more i hear about this you
know the more alarm bells ring because
we're relying on the affordable housing
delivery plan i'm not sure that that's
actually mentioned within the narrative
of the informants or the conditions so i
you know i just want to tie this up look
don't get me wrong this is good
development and i hear what people say
about design but of course those
buildings if you look in the design
guide chairman there's ones in them
so um i think this is a really important
point
i think i think i think mr lee can help
us here all right through your chairman
as mr group
blame these have already been
restricted and acquired through the
previous outline permission so these
reserve matters that draw down over that
outline commission are still tied by
those restrictions so overall the scheme
must provide this quantum of development
and
but there is no requirement to be
proportionate throughout the phases so
we are very confident because it's the
first phase that and it's only a
relatively small percentage of the
housing
that the requirement of this number will
be delivered over the rest of it it will
not prejudice the development coming
forward etcetera so there is no
requirement was no actual ability to
impose
a conditional request over future phases
through this permission because this is
a standalone reserve matters but
irrespective that there were the
requirements of the outline that says
that the housing must be provided within
these parameters so they will have to
come forward for the whole suite of
reserve matters to be granted permission
otherwise they would have to come
forward with variations of conditions or
such like to be able to play to move
that around without that they have to
deliver what they have to deliver so um
there is no way of timing in future
applications for this because it's
already been tied in through the outline
thank you chairman chairman i'm grateful
for that of course we've got that
narrative recorded so let's hope it all
delivers chairman i did make a proposal
and i think someone secondly
sorry could you remind us of your
proposal
gentlemen it was to approve the
officer's recommendation oh i see i i
think yes i understand that i think
council fleming wanted to say something
before i
indeed you can
counselor fleming
thank you chairman i just wanted to ask
the officers about long-term stewardship
of the landscaped areas i think you've
referred to it in condition seven
i just wanted to know the life span of
that whether it's at infinitum thank you
okay uh miss testo blue can you help us
with that
chairman can you uh repeat the question
mr douglas just mentioned me so you
didn't hear it
thank you
and i wanted to find out the lifetime of
the landscape management plan the
stewardship whether it was
ad infinitum
[Applause]
for the first five years um
from from the planet
thank you chairman i'm not sure quite
much i could understand i heard the
question obviously the condition relates
to five years which is in relation to
landscaping which is what is the
standard condition anything longer than
that is to be unreasonable in planning
that's quite regular but the overall
management of soft landscaping has been
dealt with through the section 106 at
the outline stage um i don't have that
information um in front of me i'm not
sure if mr does but sensing it's not
actually relevant to the termination of
this application because that will be
dealt with that was already agreed
through the management of the through
the 6 106 at one
outline stage thank you sharon that's
flowing thank you so
that that's in the 106
yeah it's it's the long-term stewardship
of the landscape
areas will you chairman it's a standard
part of 106 for outline is that
landscaping how that will be managed is
dealt with through the land the 6106
outline stage said i don't have the
details in front of us because they're
matters for phase one but that is
standard practicing thank you can i ask
another question
like i wanted to ask about informative
four about the drainage into
uh surrounding uh landowners do you have
a page number please uh yeah so 58 58
thank you
i think we're all flicking over at the
same time
informative four yeah
what's your question
so uh just was that in relation to a
particular concern
with this development i'm thinking of
surface water drainage in particular
thank you
mr glue yeah
this was a an informative suggested by
the local flood authority
that's why it was imposed it wasn't
necessarily because they did not raise
an objection to the proposal
okay thank you council swain
thank you chairman yes i've got a number
of um
questions um
two pairs actually
um the first one
there's a lot of detail in here about
the individual
um
details of the housing
um and i'm sure um the officer will tell
me if this falls outside these
particularly preserved matters or not
they concern details of the
housing
about accessibility to the first
and second floor
to bed properties
for disabled people
and
there's a
statement about light being adequate um
for all habitable rooms i wonder how
that is actually assessed who assesses
that
um and looking at the um footprint of
these buildings and the verticality of
them um
do the planning offices
appraise the actual size and usability
of the rooms within the
plans
um
to other points but about the canopies
and of the porches and so on which as i
read it will be flat roof
um probably fairly standard
unappealing ones
and i think it does make a big
difference to the appeal of the area if
they have
decent sloping canopies on their porches
as opposed to the
um well the bog standard two poles and a
flat bit of flat roof i think it makes a
big difference to the street scene
um and lastly on the weather boarding
is that plastic
or
wood and what is the sort of lifetime of
um
of this material on the building
that's the first one of the pair
oh that's the first question is right
the first pair okay i've got four there
i think
right uh mr shoglu can you help us with
those please accessibility for disabled
yeah did you get all of those
um i i believe yeah okay
for them to um accessible
was um
used to be accessible
it was introduced after the approval of
the
eslr line application
so it's quite hard for us to post such
conditions
[Music]
with regard to
uh sizes i can confirm that the advocate
has
um the applicant has confirmed that all
affordable housing units will be
uh in accordance with the ndss standards
the national standards
[Music]
i think canopies or porches but i think
that's a
that's a
cosmetic issue i think
on that weatherboarding yes
yeah
reporting
the
the ambulance stated that the
oh bear with me
material so it's going to be
[Music]
yeah no it has not been specified
whether that would be
paper but if counselors are worried
about the facing materials we can pose a
condition for
either product details or the actual
material to be submitted and approved by
the local planning authority
i remember this minded to uh impose that
as a condition yes yes you are okay
um
are we suggesting
wooden cladding
no no no
that's a voice yeah um i i would have
thought that there was a normal
condition that uh all materials uh that
are uh agreed by um the local planning
authority mr ling three chairman as
condition four states at the moment it
says the external finishing materials
for the government hereby shall be
carried out in accordance with the
details of and the materials as shown on
plan ml 01 rev b prior to occupation of
any of the dwellings if members feel
that there needs to be an assessment of
specific materials i would suggest that
that condition is replaced with uh one
requiring details to be submitted and as
counselor boy says we do have a
relatively standard condition it
wouldn't be owners for us to reword that
the question is whether or not it's
necessary and that's within the gift of
members thank you
okay um counselors fine you've got
another question well the the
the other point which i really hope the
um the applicant might take on board is
this question of the appearance of the
porches and the
front canopies of um
to
buildings and the impact it has on the
attractiveness of the streets in the
second one this was um and it follows on
to some extent from
um
to some extent from what council of luca
said um when i went through this there
were numerous um
parts where it said
the
um
plan fell short
on a number of things but in each case
it said
this is not sufficient reason to refuse
the application and i wondered how many
times
one here's that before one thinks well
perhaps one should refuse it um a number
of these seem to have been dealt with
now um
so i i don't make a great point of that
at this stage but though i do think the
amount of visitor parking is
is under um it is going to be a problem
um and the question relating to what the
one that council fluke raised as well is
uh shortfalls on things like bungalows
and so on and
what confidence we can have that they
will be compensated for if there is no
actual overall plan at this stage
otherwise we do run into the problem um
the situation where we'll find at the
final stage uh we get the pleading that
can't be done or it's not viable um so i
mean it's certainly something we need to
look out for may i move on to the other
points chairman i'm sorry i thought you
had yes
yes
um
the first thing is this application
originated in 2015
and an awful lot has happened since then
particularly regarding energy
conservation and climate change and so
on right and numerous statements from
government about
the need to be prepared for uh reducing
carbon emissions and so on um and i
i would suggest i assume that all those
statements are in fact material
considerations
and therefore need to be taken into
account mention was made of electric
charging points but there are all sorts
of other things
um which
i would hope the applicant has thought
about such as
solar panels and
heat pumps and this sort of thing as
well as the charging points
um
my last point concerns informative
number five
i'm not quite sure i understand what
that is about
on page 58
it seems to imply that um
that the um
the viability of the
um the flood or the
water disposal system is um
beyond the scope of the
the flood authority
and that it's the responsibility of the
district council
um if i'm writing that uh are
we saying that district council
has the capability of monitoring
the
um
flooding issues
from this development
do you have a chance to absolutely
uh mr glue can you help
um
[Music]
yeah and all i've said in the report is
that this this has been secured by a
condition imposed for the original
permission so the details of the
following will have to be submitted and
approved by the local authority
yeah
okay which i think that con informative
five is from suds and it's just a
standard one it's that they've requested
um to be honest i'm not actually sure it
really ties in properly with this
application as a reserve matters with no
such details included but obviously
we've included it as their
recommendation thank you
okay um i see your hand counselor again
but i'll go to counselor why just
briefly yeah thank you so one quick one
i'm just going from councillor fleming's
point um do we know if the downstream
landowners have given their consent
and what happens if they don't give
their consent just out of curiosity
chairman formative four is highlighting
that it's a civil matter
and or common law in this case but um it
isn't a material situation determination
of uh
this application and i know what members
are going to say that we only in
planning can look at what we're gifted
to uh
take into account and common law civil
matters uh
covenants etc all not matters for the
planning determination of an application
so
i'm not really about to say much more on
that whatever questions you've
posed to me and ms tash talked about
that thank you chairman okay counselor
i'll go to council lagging next
weighted counsellor okay council fleming
cancer fleming thank you chairman thank
you councillor lagan um i raised this
because i actually took my
lovely dog for a walk along i think it's
called grapnolf grappanol's farm chase
um
so it goes up to that it's outside of
the development site
and it had been raining that day and
there was an awful lot of surface water
pouring down that track
in fact part of it is sort of piped
above ground
which is why i'm concerned about i think
when we had the
reserved matters in relation to the uh
relief road and the drainage we put an
informative honor
to
that the developer could covenant that
the driveways must be permeable um
because you know anyone that's familiar
with the site knows that it is
surface water drainage is a real issue
there so i don't know whether mr lee
feels that that
might be
relevant here if we could put that
informative on again
thank you so yeah um
be a little bit to the point no
i think i think this application is
reserved matters um we've dealt with the
matters of unsustainable drainage under
the outline you know did has been posed
there as i said i'm
i'm not really sure actually how
relevant taking account what this
application is for how appropriate these
um informatives are for this application
obviously as it's a major we have to
consult the suds they're a statutory
consulting or major application that it
serve matters full outline um no matter
what it's for um and they've recommended
that so well that's why we've imposed
them but
take into account what actually this
application is from what we've already
granted and the other conditions we've
been posing restrictions
i don't think that would be appropriate
this instant thank you chad all right
cancer lagging
thank you um just got a couple of points
and a question the the first point of
say 10 this is recorded our labor town
at that place it's going to flood
it always has done and it always will it
will flood and we are where we are
um just so i know on the proposal page
at the top
are these points guaranteed like the
primary school and that the road they
will come on at some point so they are
guaranteed that's it that was going to
get what it's what it's surely needs
yeah
can i have a verbal so it's recording
please the chairman on the assumption
that all of the phases come through and
all of the development is ever delivered
there are requirements of various stages
some of it
is outside our gift in relation to
delivery but
in the planning system yes as much as we
can guarantee
that is a yes thank you
and there is a risky right
um the planning system used to require
contributions at 100 delivery it doesn't
do that anymore because it learned that
people only built 99 out of 100 houses
there's always a certain level of risk
but
i think the way it's now cascaded it
means it's very unlikely that it
wouldn't happen
thank you thank you
and as the gentleman spoke as an
award-winning person i'm sure they'll
eat their morals and their their
commitments to deliver what they say and
what which desperately needs
um
the
i this is always my bug bear it's the
graphics that come through
because we're talking about appearance
um
can some will the developer one day
please put a graphic when all the cars
are parked and the bins are out and the
cars apart and it's difficult to get
around because at the moment there's
only three people that live here and
there's only one bloke because i've got
a bike
you know so
i i can't trust
this
you know i'm not i don't mean to be
literally subject for but to me it's how
can i go actually that if that's what
was created i think that's a fantastic
thing and the planners know how to plan
and the developers know how to develop
but from a local boys perspective how do
i ensure that people are going to be
living in what i see here and the other
thing is and it's a question about trees
in in these these lovely um little
visuals they've got some pretty
full-sized trees
are they actually going to be put in at
full size or are we going to have
smaller trees that take 30 years to grow
before we'll actually get a street scene
that actually looks like that because we
need that desperately for the
environment because we're taking away so
much of this green land
um to build housing and i know we can't
do anything about this development
i'm not a fan of these estates you know
that
yeah that's that's fair but i have to
determine it on what's in front of me so
i just need to know that what this thing
actually looks like is going to be that
they're going to get the infrastructure
that they need and it is going to be a
nice place for people to live
and look flat
okay i think i think i have i have an
observation on that that we can't we
can't limit the number of cars that a
resident has if they choose to have a
caravan or a speed boat etc in in the
drives but i hear what you're saying but
of course we're here to determine the
planning of the buildings not not the
street furniture if you like that that
goes with that
just just won't come back to just one
tiny bit but it because it's in the pack
i think it's fair and relevant that one
should take that into consideration and
i'm i'm
very much um
yeah we hear this the five-year land
supply and we have to build well i think
there's a challenge coming on how that's
calculated because uh there's new
information coming forward but the the
last point is also about there's a
discussion about members and officers
and again i think that was very valid
that what members because
we the members are you know with the
bridal ways issues etc and the things
that are very passionate to people who
are elected people that represent local
interests
rather than the planners can just say
well
we did we don't going to put them in you
know things like that would have ticked
the box and we would have been somewhere
further down the road so they're more
observations and concerns from from the
chair and i get what you say thank you
okay thank you very much
council swine yes
it's just one one point councillor
fleming has reminded me of something was
was going to point out and that is this
reference to permeable parking it seems
to me that that comes back to my point
about um
dealing with the changing environment as
being material consideration and i think
it's extremely disappointing that um the
whole areas are not permeable i think
it's essential these days the too many
driveways being
carpeted over with block
block paving autonomou
okay right okay so members uh
we have uh the recommendation here is to
approve subject to the conditions as
detailed in section eight of the report
we do have a proposal to uh
yes casafluka i think i think members
are minded to add this
to change condition number four on page
55 where i think mr lee suggested that
the change should be
um with regards to the details and
materials being submitted
um so i would propose that chairman as a
as a changed condition an amendment
condition for
and subject to that chairman
continue with my proposal that we agree
the recommendation thank you and council
helm you're happy to second that
proposal
right are you okay with that yeah okay
um so members uh can we agree that by
ascent
yes castlevania
okay uh that is uh your descent is noted
thank you
okay agenda item six
is any other items well to say that is
that is carried anyway um
so in
agenda item six is any other items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent i have none
uh therefore members and officers i
thank you for your contributions this
evening my thanks also to those watching
the live stream and i draw the meeting
to close at 20 25.